en la Guatemala acusada por la extorsión
y la violencia de las maras la candidata
presidencial sur y ríos promete ser
implacable
de armamento de tecnología de vehículos
un guiño que le hace a bukele en El
Salvador en su guerra contra las
pandillas para que se cumpla la ley
por sus venas corre la sangre del
dictador de Guatemala Efraín Ríos montt
quien fue condenado por genocidio
indígena y murió en la impunidad creo
que no es correcto verdad tachar a una
persona por lo que han hecho los padres
ya que es de cierta forma independiente
de tomar sus acciones y sus decisiones
verdad en pro del pueblo
en 2015 y 2019 la ley le había impedido
postularse a unas elecciones por ser
hija de un general que tomó el poder por
las armas pero en 2023 la corte
constitucional avaló su candidatura para
aspirar a ser la primera mujer
presidenta de Guatemala
por las mujeres Por supuesto que sí
somos el 54% de las empadronadas
[Música]
en su trayecto político sur y ríos fue
congresista durante 16 años por el
partido que fundó su padre para estos
comicios representa la coalición valor
unionista para que la población decida
el cambio histórico y no permitamos que
el socialismo del siglo XXI llegue a
nuestro país en la semana decisiva
electoral
recibió mensajes de apoyo de los
expresidentes de chile Sebastián Piñera
y de Colombia Álvaro Uribe